hey everybody and it's our second movie
review yeah this is the Hunger yes this
is Jenny's choice I know this is one of
my favorite movies definitely my
favorite vampire movie I think yeah it's
a good one I've seen it many times I saw
I saw right after it came out it was in
the mid 80s
thank you name is rien cameras yeah from
the first time at then I thought when I
was a couple years old girls yeah I know
I didn't see it in the theater so much
of them VHS
yeah well the thing is I'm not like a
huge like I like some vampire movies I
like kind of your classic vampire movies
and stuff like that but kind of after my
Anne Rice phase past when I was my
teenage years and in my early 20s I kind
of got sick of vampires right you know I
mean Hillary out yeah I was like super
into and stuff and then I was kind of
like mint you know it's kind of like the
way I feel about zombies now cuz they're
just everywhere I remember who first
showed me this movie that was my friend
Jason Jason Quinlan and it showed to me
because it opened with Bauhaus well see
I got very funny because okay the movie
came out of 1983 I didn't see it until
probably a few years later when up
because I was in high school and you're
the same like you know I grew up like
really into goth music and I was really
getting into Bauhaus and alien sex fiend
and all that kind of stuff and one of my
friends I can't remember which one but
she told me oh this is vampire movie
called The Hunger David Bowie is in it
and Bauhaus are in it and you have to
see it I had never heard of it so I went
and rented it at the little sketchy VHS
rental place nearby house and this movie
oh this is like the God the
quintessential Gothic movie yeah it is
the time everything it has everything
okay Bauhaus are in it Zoey's antics
hands [ __ ] yeah and it likes it
all the people in it are sexy it looks
like like it's all dark and Creed it had
a classic feel to it
yeah and it was kind of like Art Nouveau
kind of feel to it from what I remember
yeah they had like um the Blaylock had
like this really cool like New York
apartment like with this attic that had
like all these [ __ ] curtains blowing
around all elegantly and like pigeons
flying or
if you haven't seen in the skylight
haven't seen it you should see it is it
origin bad word is to look at it's a
vampire movie but it's a vampire movie
that kind of is unlike any of the others
nah eh no vampire it's really not well
it has a very Egyptian theme to it yeah
and it's not the kind of immortality you
were promised or you yeah and yeah
that's it that's another thing that I
liked about it is just that it kind of
did something different with I'm and
that wasn't from the movie that was from
the novel but basically so the novel was
written by Whitley streamer now I read
the book wobbly and again he gets
abducted by a guy who got abducted by
aliens and communion guys that's what
yeah he is kind of know that I've
listened to him I just I'm not really I
just can't buy the alien yeah he really
if you didn't know Whitley Strieber does
actually the book communion that's like
it he says that the true story yeah
you've got to he got interview did he
say he got probed I don't remember I
don't think so no but the first thing
your interviews you saw he's constantly
being abducted out of his bedroom the
military's involved aliens are involved
dimensional doors it's a whole thing
young yeah it's extremely far-fetched I
think there might be something wrong
mrs. Trevor this is Brian yeah I
actually I admit I have not read
communion but I have read The Hunger the
book was actually pretty good yeah the
thing I like the movie a lot better
because it's great one thing I did like
about the book is that they went a lot
more into Miriam Blaylock history like
her past in the movie they kind of only
give a sort of you know which I guess is
fair enough because it's not really the
main part of the plot but they only give
a few flashbacks is how long she's been
alive and things like that they show her
like in in ancient Egypt and you know
they show her in the French Revolution
or whatever it was something like that
now I don't remember because like I said
it's been many years since I read the
book I don't remember if they actually
say because I don't think they really
say this in the movie but she so she was
made in ancient Egypt they do say that
in the book that her mother was Lamia
who was the Greek mythology
kind of banshee vampire type of singer
so that was her mother so she's so she
actually was created at
some point or was born at some point but
the book in the movie I don't know if
they really specify if she is the only
one of her kind yes yeah because in the
universe of the movie she's the really
the only one and she doesn't have fangs
or anything like that she just looks
like a normal person yeah
albeit very elegant and lovely yeah but
what she ends up doing is that because
she has lived for such a long time and
because she often gets lonely so what
she does is she will find a companion
either male or female and she will you
know exchange blood with him yeah she
cuts him cut a vein yeah yeah so she
doesn't bite memory even like that it's
not only necklace her form I remember
head yeah it's like an awkward the blade
I laid on and she cuts them to threaten
a drink and they have a blood exchange
or she gives them her blood or whatever
and her blood has some kind of virus in
it that gives her companions not eternal
life no it's a turn right well it's
eternal life but not eternal youth right
which is the [ __ ] that's the kicker
right there because what happens is and
this has happened to all of her
companions is that the companion will
live for a few hundred years yeah
without aging without aging and then
they will rapidly start to age but they
still won't die yeah they just end up
being Kylie these corpse like mummified
yeah things that can't even move and
then she keeps him around which I
thought was like I thought this is one
of the coolest things and this is one of
the coolest things about the movie I
have to tell you I love Catherine
Deneuve I've seen I think I've seen
every movie she's been in even all the
French ones so I would actually I would
recommend repulsion which she made in
the 60s that was Roman Polanski and
Belle de Jour that's not a horror movie
but it's but it's really good it's in
French
but um she was awesome in that but she
makes the perfect vampire and she's so
good in this because she's a monster
but you also kind of feel bad for her
like she's sympathetic I didn't have a
choice she's got it she's got to have
somebody to hang out with yeah
means she does extend their lives
several hundred writers and like I said
the price of bed she'd evidently can't
bring herself to kill them if they're if
it's possible to kill him yeah I guess
she just can't bring him substitute well
see that's yeah that's kind of not
really made clear like I said I think in
the universe of the movie I think she's
probably the only one of her kind right
which would be sad for anybody I mean
but you know that you're trying to have
a companion to spend the rest of your
eternity with and they don't last as
long as you would like you know so I
feel like she keeps doing this to these
people which is monstrous because I do
feel like she promises them that I'm
going to make you a vampire we'll live
forever and we'll be awesome yes a lot
but it's a lie they will live forever
yeah yeah they do live forever but they
won't but yeah so and they'll be
together forever because she keeps them
up in the attic remember yeah she does
the the companion will not be young no
they'll basically just be a dusty yeah
right like an end like an invalid
yeah pretty bad and then and I guess
they're living in a hellish existence
yes because they're moaning and stuff
yeah well yeah she K so the hunger if
you guys have not seen it because this
seems weird because I feel like a lot of
people have seen maybe kind of your
bigger-ticket
vampire movies interview with the
vampire and you know blade and all that
kind of [ __ ] the hunger I feel like
probably our generation I feel like a
lot of people have seen it but I feel
like younger people maybe it kind of
went under the radar baby but I think
it'd be slow for a young person well
it's like I said it's very um it's kind
of arty yeah so it's more of you know
it's more of like an upscale vampire
it's not like a slasher I want gory yeah
I need to say it
it is a chick flick I think but it's one
of the better ones I've got a guy will
like it yeah yeah if you have enough
patience with and it doesn't have biceps
it doesn't have machine guns are those
maptags things don't blow up so it's bad
yeah it's cool it's cool
you love Bowie yeah yeah
yeah it's cool it's a cool click but so
yeah so what doesn't have a creepy
element to it yeah it's not it's not an
action movie no I need by any stretch
its gory it's got some happens they've
got some goring yeah it is weird it is a
weird movie so the plot of the movie is
that Catherine Deneuve who is named
Marion Blaylock has been married to her
present companion David Bowie whose name
is John in the movie for probably 200
years something like that it looks like
they met sometime in the 18th century
yeah or somewhere there about and he's
young during the time that he made this
movie a baby I'd say early 30s would you
say yeah yeah was made in 1983 so
suddenly so they've apparently been
together all she has all this money and
they live in this beautiful this
beautiful brownstone in New York City
and suddenly John begins to age just
like in a few days like the first thing
he notices age spots and that his hair
starts to fall out this is another
reason why I think that
Miriam's character is kind of
sympathetic because she tells him hey
I've been studying this doctor her name
is Sarah and she's played by Susan
Sarandon this doctor is like a
gerontologist and she's studying aging
and hoping someday that they can reverse
it so Miriam has been studying this
woman's worth and she's like super up on
all the latest stuff so she's hoping
that John will be the companion that
will live forever so she is actively
trying to do something rough to you know
help him out on the other hand this is
not explicitly said in the movie but
it's implied the couple have a music
student who's she looks about 1314 years
old maybe she's a little bit older her
name is Alice a Miriam is actually
grooming Alice to be her next companion
I didn't realize if this [ __ ] with John
doesn't work out so she's got a back-up
plan right like I said this is not
explicit I think it's actually more
explicit in the book than it is in the
movie but it's implied it suggests
in the movie Casey starts agent yes
because she knows it's happened over and
over
so let's know about how long it lasts
and about when it starts kicking in yeah
she probably figured that you know the
girl would be a few years older but by
the time it happens Ryder you know so
David Bowie he goes to see this doctor
and susan sarandon who is actually
really good in this I like her a lot
she's very no nonsense and all this
other stuff so obviously she does not
believe him you know she he brings in a
Polaroid as a glove this boy was taken a
couple days ago a couple days ago I was
35 years old and now he looks like a 70
year old man and I only got a couple of
days and she's like [ __ ] get out of
here with that she just thinks he's a
nut but then while he's sitting there
she's like kind of blowing him off and
she's like just let him wait in the
waiting room and he'll get bored and go
home it's fine and so in the time that
he's sitting there he ages so much that
by the time he's like leaving like [ __ ]
des Susan Sarandon and seen him she sees
him and she's like oh my god it looks so
much different correct so she's like no
wait come back and he's like nah [ __ ]
all that so he leaves so basically what
ends up happening is that as I said
Miriam has been grooming Alice to be the
next companion except Alice comes to the
house when Miriam isn't there and John
eat sir what she wasn't supposed to do
right woody was agent he but he was
aging and he and he thought that it
might help row since the girl was so
young I'm thinking that so he either is
just richer blood well he drinks her
okay they don't really eat they don't
run eat people
I don't remember that I remember him yes
we drink her blood so when Miriam comes
home she's like hey I was gonna use that
you know what I mean so after that John
pretty much starts to age and he looks
like an old actually the old man makeup
and this is very good yeah from what I
remember yeah so he ends up just looking
like a mummy pretty much so she's like
well time for you to go up to the attic
now honey sorry and she put them in a
box does she just carry them up yeah and
it's actually kind of like a sad
horrifying scene at the same time she's
got all these coffin like led coffins up
in the attic and she lays them in just
because I guess she keeps empty ones
around her it's just such a purpose
which is what I wanted what about
thinking I remember think at the time we
said it's kind of weird that she was
able to hide all that stuff up there
yeah for that amount of time well I mean
if you have a lot of years if you have
[ __ ] tons of money I guess she can get
away before okay so good you know how
did he not find out over 200 years worth
of time about this well and they had all
these costs the thing though I did a
move I think I did no because I think
that she mentioned some of her earlier
lovers okay so I think he did know about
Nona I think that he was just thinking
might wouldn't happen then it wouldn't
happen to him and I think that's
probably how she got away with all of
her former lovers who she said oh well
sometimes it happens but it was not
going to happen to you we'll get it out
by then or whatever I'm sure she sold
them something like that yeah yes if she
just like lays into this coffin and then
she like asks the other and the other
corpses the other living corpses to like
look after him no I mean because there's
also alive in there right because she
won't kill them right so so like I said
it's terrible and sick but you feel kind
of bad for her too so this Alice is dead
she starts going after the doctor Sarah
and so this leads to like seriously
super hot lesbian scene between festered
the demonstrations every odd about that
really yeah I forgot that's usually the
scene everybody thinks of so you know if
you ever wanted to see a lesbian scene
be sweet and student Sarandon and
Catherine Deneuve here's your chance so
while they're you know doing the nasty
Miriam drink some of her blood or gifts
what does she do she drinks out of her
arm or something like that so I think
Susan Sarandon at first doesn't really
realize what's happened until she starts
actually starts acting real funny like
she starts she loses her appetite and
she starts getting real crabby and all
of a sudden her boyfriends like what's a
[ __ ] amount of you know and all this
other stuff and she's like [ __ ] man then
and then she starts seeing visions of
Miriam around and stuff like that so she
goes back to ask like what did you do
and they test her blood because I
gently I think the boyfriend think their
sink thinks there's something weird
going on Sarah I marry which there is so
you know he could call there but he
tests her blood and they see this virus
in there so then she figures out that
Miriam gave her this disease grow but it
turns out that a suited student Sarandon
ends up killing the boyfriend because
the hunger overwhelmed her and stuff and
then Miriam's like see is it it's not
that hard you know you can do this and
all this other because they do kill
people and drink their blood you know
it's not like they're just like cool
hitman sort of thing like that did you
actually burn her people and she hasn't
actually Miriam has a big furnace in the
cellar that she is the burn alarm up
yeah but so Susan Sarandon is acting all
like yeah and I was no big and all this
other stuff but then she grabs Miriam's
off pendant and stabs herself in the
neck and then makes Miriam drink her
blood okay
now here's the weird thing at the end is
that Miriam does actually end up dying
and all of her former lovers end up
dying too like they all finally get
mummified they all released which is
what they wanted now okay the movie has
kind of a stupid little coda at the end
and Sue Sarandon was actually really
pissed off that they put this at the end
because she said it negated the whole
point of the story and her character arc
and everything like that now at the very
end of the movie there's like a couple
minutes where they show Susan Sarandon
who's still alive because even though
she cut her throat open everything she
still had Miriam the vampire blood in
him so apparently she's either the main
vampire now or she's going to live for
several hundred years so they show Susan
Sarandon coming out on a balcony like
somewhere in London or something like
that and then she has like two of her
own companions and running a woman like
she has become Miriam now and sit and
see okay now this one is she like that
well the studio made them put that there
in case the movie did really good and
they could make a sequel oh good student
surrender being the vampire and she's
like that is dumb as hell because she's
like the whole point of Susan Sarandon
character was that she didn't want to be
a vampire she was trying to kill herself
she was trying to kill there
you know and stuff like that she's like
she didn't want that
yeah the week from didn't want to be a
vampire yeah true yes
but yeah I understand why they did it I
understand why they did it to you but
she just said she thought it was done
because she's like the whole point of
the character was that she didn't want
to be a vampire and she was willing to
die and so I yeah I take it the movie
didn't do that well well it didn't
because it well I kind of got mixed
reviews yeah
now you have to realize this was it was
directed by Tony Scott who was obviously
who was Ridley Scott younger brother and
this was his first feature film prior to
this he had only done commercials and
things of that nature later on
weirdly he would go on to do he did Top
Gun he did Days of Thunder yeah nothing
like a movie blah yeah this is like
nothing like that for real
the thing about Tony Scott is that I
mean he has like a really cool not so
much in Top Gun and stuff like that but
in the Hunger he had a really cool
visual style and I think what happened
is that when the movie came out he kind
of got mad because it felt like a
particularly a lot of American critics
accused the movie of being style over
substance which is the most common
criticism I see a movie they said it
looks like a music video and not a movie
and we're not looking like that I
remember looking sophisticated that's a
good word for that it looks
sophisticated it looked like an
expensive European movie it did yes but
look what that's what I remembered it
looking like so it didn't occur to me
that it was just all visuals over
because it had like a really intricate
plot yeah and a really interesting kind
of metaphorical yeah disease and I have
no wrong with I agree she has aneurysm I
appreciated it I saw it a couple times
for different reasons you know Mel the
people watching it things like that but
it really I didn't find it to be a very
compelling movie but I understand what I
understand why people like it yeah
there's just you know my my fault for it
you're not abandoned by that I wouldn't
give it a thumbs down I was just kind of
I was lukewarm about it yeah it didn't
have any action no like I said it's a
very it's more like an artsy yeah they
are tired moving our scene like I said
it's super bloody there's particularly
toward the end you know that opening
scene or the club was Bauhaus when Peter
Murphy when you
when he was hot rock like this behind
the the cage and everything like that it
had David Bowie and it had it you know
and it just had like you said it has
this kind of sophisticated veneer that a
lot of it was even a lot more than you
know something like interview with the
vampire yes it was yeah it was
definitely more something that girls
would appreciate and when they would
appreciate it yeah wasn't a guy's play a
guy could watch it but it was like the
target audience was this way there's no
explosion than it is no he was notes
blown encloses I think the target the
target audience I believe is women yeah
yeah you know nothing wrong with that
just that I wasn't really in targeted
yeah that's okay you don't have to be
trying it over time to be caught like
back in the day oh if you want to take a
check out and go see the split no no man
and it was like your first date that was
a movie you could sit through whether an
open joy and if you took her to see that
movie then maybe she would let you put
your hand on her boob professionally to
use object yeah especially well yeah
that way if I like that I did for fun
yeah exactly and that's when I said it
killed me because I got into God through
in probably like 84 85 like probably
only a year or two after this movie came
out and it amazed me that I didn't
really see it and so I think I saw it in
87 88 I want to say something like that
and it surprised me that it took so long
for me to see it right cuz I'm like I
what I was watching it I couldn't
believe it
I was kind of just like I want to live
in this movie I'm like this is what I
want my life to be like you know I mean
it was just I was like this is like
everything I ever met like every like
goth fantasy like imagine like right
there oh and after I know I mean it's
like it adds everything it's not
affiliated I don't remember having an
over-the-top not really but it was just
an idea I was like yeah it just had that
kind of like romanticism area it had
like all the we always uh it's kinda
like the dark new romantic time yeah
it's very like that like a dark Duran
Duran yeah yeah yeah it was it had just
like the right of luxury and the next
eNOS and crowd were [ __ ] pride where
they got
the it also kind of reminded me a little
bit of Blade Runner yeah it's a similar
a little bit similar why does dark not
mean I didn't really have like the dark
cityscapes all the time you know no it
was my baby guy than that Wow and the
architecture they showed what people
were wearing kind of reminded me of like
the business suits and stuff out of
Blade Runner and but that's just stop
stop by it well which I get the good
because you know release got an oh yeah
rut yes um you know and unfortunately
Tony Scott uh committed suicide in 2002
he jumped off a bridge in Los Angeles I
don't know why but um he was mad
well Ridley Scott said that he had
terminal cancer oh but I don't know if
that's the case or not but that's what
his brother said and then he didn't and
that they didn't want anyone to know
about it or whatever we left a note but
no one none the family said what it was
but um it's kind it kind of made me sad
too because I was actually reading the
Wikipedia page so so whatever happened
to Tony Scott man then I was like oh
yeah I forgot he made Top Gun and
Crimson Tide and he made like all kind
of different mostly action movies
honestly uh but um and I was looking at
whatever happened to him because I saw
that he had died and I was like I really
Scott the older so I don't know but this
and it was sad too because as soon as
the hunger came out he was like well I'm
not even going to read the press anymore
because he's like they just [ __ ] on me
for the movie be looking like a music
video no he just made commercials before
in love life like everyone just bitched
so I just don't breathe that only
depressing huh and he got like hugely
famous later on like we're making some
not fix it with style over substance the
very most common criticism which I think
yet in it no I didn't either
i I think that's a really unfair
comparison is a movie that gravitas it
did and yeah and it has like like I said
it had a lot of metaphorical scenes and
stuff like that going on it's like I
really it's not like it had some nothing
plot I think it was just saying that it
had maybe had thin ice in plot that's
probably what you're saying but yeah I
really agree with that anywhere though
this probably would not agree with
they're probably trying to say that well
it's kind of cliche it's kind of I don't
think so then alright what they thought
like I said I thought it was a very
original take on the vampire mythos
honestly one of our most original ones
they ever met yeah and it's hard to be
original with vampire stories very hard
it really is and that's why I kind of
and I guess you have to give most of the
credit to Whitley Schreiber on it
because he's the one that came up with
the idea you know the gerontologists and
studying aging and the virus and the
blood and stuff like that I think it's
been done a lot of times since then but
it hadn't really done been done much I
mean I'm not saying vampires have always
been used as like plague metaphors and
stuff like that ever since Dracula
probably even before that but you know
what I mean it seems like a
modernization of that and it really
seemed like an original take I was
cumbered being kind of art deco looking
yeah it was yeah well she had a lot of
like in there in their house yeah she
had like a lot of really classical -
yeah you know she had all these big
marble busts and yes stuff like that
they played classical music there's like
a lot of really cool you know classical
pieces and I think a lot of it was
Schubert actually but um things and deli
they had that opera with the - it's
called Lakme I think there was a lot of
that in there I've seen it so long after
I like I said yeah I would like it
better now yeah I think I have it on DVD
that's where my sort of primal 18 yeah
see and I think you would appreciate it
a lot more now right then you went back
then comes back to you the booth oh yeah
mm you know mm agency whatever mean I
just you dad you're still finding out
that but then we have punch me to face I
could bear with the idea but yeah art
lvoe I would let her me I would let her
make me wait out there bridge yeah but
yeah you know but yeah you should see it
again because actually I watched it
again probably a year or two ago now I
see it I have to tell you I've seen it a
billion times probably man women are
yeah this evening was a movie over Tommy
well like you know when I was younger I
feel like I don't want to say movies or
no that's right the other day you watch
the same thing batteries or whatever
more than me that's for sure usually if
I unless I really really super love
something like if I see something once
or twice I'm like yeah cos enough but
you know how many times have you seen
like
atheist eye products watch Prometheus
about 12 times yes II yeah I rest my
case
yeah so I'm just saying I haven't seen
the hunger of billion times but I
probably legit seen it at least two
dozen times probably more than that I
think are worth these fifty fast yeah I
think I probably got you I've seen Rocky
Horror Picture Show probably about a
hunch but I mean the hunger I think I
probably mostly have it memorized to be
honest with you but I watched I hadn't
watched it for many years then I watched
it again recently I honestly think that
that has aged better than any vampire
movie from the 80s near dark is good too
if you guys haven't seen that when
they're dark is also verb maybe I should
do that one I haven't seen that in a
long time but um for me easily easily
one of the best vampire movies of the
80s easily for me the best would be
interviewed the vampire just hands down
that's the best movie I think I liked it
but I thought it was a little uneven and
I wish they would have well I wish they
would have made the vampire lestat a
standalone movie instead of kind of
shoehorning it into Queen of the Damned
in the green widow song like I don't
know why they did that
I liked interview with the vampire but I
don't know something about it there was
just like little things about it the bug
made but all in all I liked it and like
I said I expected to hate it because I
don't like Tom Cruise but he was
actually a good in it I think it was
really good in it yeah and you know what
it's funny because we were watching um
what's that guy's name that Oliver's
retrospectives or what yeah I forgot
that the movie reviews were watching and
we watched the one of legend last night
which I love ledge I mean Tim Curry is
the devil yeah that's he's like the best
part of that and I totally forgot that
Tom Cruise's in it and I totally forgot
that Ridley Scott directed that I forgot
what Tom Cruise looked like he was young
well he looked like a normal person now
he's just like I don't know what he
looks like now a Scientology bot or
something I don't know what it is but
yeah so like I said I feel like The
Hunger is sort of one of the more
underrated vampire movies of the 80s
yeah it's kind of more chicks like it's
more artsy fartsy it's more European
kind of aesthetic to it and stuff like
that but you know if you like that kind
of thing and you can live without having
versions
and or if you're a young guy that's kind
of into goth chicks and you yeah and you
want to give it a knowledgeable yeah
then your usual hunger then take your
girlfriend to this she's a hunger
because yeah y'all will be all about
that anslee if there's lesbian sex in it
too so yeah so there's something for
everyone it was must have been mostly
not have been all that because I forgot
about it
I find that hard okay and like I said
it's like you know it has some gory like
you know some corpsey effects and
there's like a lot of blood I can't
remember that mmm rollers yeah those old
vampires open it up in the attic that
was the creepiest part I thought yeah
like them all coming through the
skylight and it was all the birds and
everything like that that was dead
pretty rad I thought now all the space
is coming at her and she was like Wiggin
out it's a really I mean I know we
spoiled the whole thing but I told you
on the last show I'm gonna spoil every
movie so I'm sorry I just can't help it
I mean it to me it was cool I liked it I
guess it didn't make a huge impact I
didn't see it in the theater maybe it
was another factor
I didn't whether I saw BHS that's how I
saw was maybe 19 maybe I'd like it more
better now but I said yeah I should dig
my DVD I think I have it on DVD I'd be
surprised if I didn't I'm sure it's
probably in one of those boxes with my
million DVDs that I had from back in the
day we should rewatch it though but yeah
so I hope you guys enjoyed this second
installment of our movie retrospective
what do you think we're gonna do that I
have no idea I don't know maybe uh
predator und president or Omega man okay
shave from New York well I did I did
dying to do those three but I did I just
did it we did it carpenter flick yeah
sure maybe I'll just finish it with
carbon okay
so maybe a little bit we might do
another carpet depends on how few yeah
old yoga so hope you guys enjoyed this
one um remember to support us on patreon
yeah HRE on complex 13 o'clock podcast
and remember to listen to the regular 13
o'clock podcast every tuesday and
that'll do it buh